between women
[Music]
as for him manages he
is a very appreciated member sorry
eh we
are tired of testing
why what is happening you are doing
too many tests
[Music]
because with my children we have some  tired
of being tested every other day we
started testing nelson and elsa on
friday pascal szym suspicion of testing
only empty in nelson's class
so friday then after sunday then
after tuesday then we received a
letter from the principal yesterday  to tell us
that in the desert class there is still a suspicion
of driving so we will
have to test them again today
and then again in two days and again
in four days so we are not getting out of it
every four mornings we are
told  institution decaux quickly in a
class you have to spend your time testing
the children he can't stand having
a test put in their noses I do
n't know how it's going